et en espagne le 11 septembre marque
aussi la fête de la catalogne l'occasion
de réaffirmer les revendications
indépendantistes
elle met cette année entre locaux vides
19 et un nouveau président de la région
plus modérée l'ambiance était différente
les précisions de clémentine rend à
barcelone
une fête de la catalogne -
indépendantistes au moins au niveau
politique c'est comme cela que l'on
pourrait qualifier ce 11 septembre j'en
ai aussi appelé la diada ici en
catalogne alors chaque année cette fête
est un événement très symbolique ici
parce que depuis presque 10 ans bien
c'est l'occasion pour les
indépendantistes d'affirmer leurs
revendications à travers un défilé et
des meetings en 2012 par exemple le
cette fête a été un petit peu l'occasion
de lancer le processus indépendantistes
et puis le défilé avait soutenu en 2010
est le référendum d'autodétermination et
puis la dame arc aussi la rentrée
politique pour l'année à venir mais
cette année l'ambiance est un petit peu
différente en cause les divisions entre
les partis indépendantistes du parlement
régional et puis il ya aussi le nouveau
président catalan père aragonès c'est un
indépendantiste certes mais il est plus
modérée que l'ancien président car
l'esprit gimone le message indépendance
est donc beaucoup plus diffus que les
dernières éditions mais cela n'empêche
pas les partisans de l'indépendance
catalane de l'année leurs revendications
dans le cortège je vous propose de les
écouter
la participation est plus faible
qu'avant les gens se sont démotivés à
cause des politiques qu'ils y croient
moins ils pensaient que l'indépendance
arriverait tout de suite mais ça tarde
et c'est un problème pour certains
il faut sortir dans la rue et continuer
car la lutte ne doit pas s'arrêter si on
ne revendique pas nos libertés ça va
empirer et avec l'excusé de la pandémie
on va nous enlever nos droits
fondamentaux comme celui de se
rassembler
les responsables politiques
indépendantistes sont divisés ils n'ont
pas assez de courage pour déclarer
l'indépendance donc nous sommes surtout
venus pour leur mettre la pression et
pour qui nous mène vers la république
catalan c'est ce que veut plus de 52% de
la population
là n'est pas seulement différente cette
année au niveau politique les mesures
sanitaires joue aussi et même si ici en
catalogne et bien il n'y a plus de
limites aux réunions sociale la foule du
cortège peut toujours provoquer
certaines réticences notamment chez les
personnes âgées qui sont habituellement
très nombreuses lors de la diada